as we wait to find out whether Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis will or won't
throw his hat into the ring to try to be
the Republican Presidential nominee I
want to go through the most likely
reasons why Donald Trump's 2024 run
could be a complete and total disaster
now before we jump into the reasons
remember that since his announcement
which was really low energy people
trying to walk out of the ballroom at
Mar-A-Lago as the announcement was still
going on one of the lowest energy
presidential announcements I've ever
seen Trump has barely left his house for
the month since the announcement
everything that's going on is strange
new polling is very bad for Trump and
we'll talk about that in a moment so
that's sort of like the the preface but
I also want to add to the preface no
matter what I say here we're not
counting Trump out he shouldn't be
counted out this was a mistake that was
made in 2016. we still don't know what's
going to happen as Joe Walsh told us
yesterday
for now Trump is still at the top of the
party however there are things that are
different this time around we have a
former president who lost and is now
running again after not being president
for four years those are not common
circumstances in addition that former
president who's running again is losing
in early polling to a guy who hasn't
even announced that he's running for
anything Ron DeSantis so this is really
an unprecedented situation now I get
emails from people saying David I
generally am hearing oh this could be
bad for Trump this could go bad what are
the most pre present I guess I would say
risks of how this could go poorly okay
let's go through them in no particular
order number one
Trump might and it appears that he will
face significant opposition from within
the Republican party some Republicans
see Trump's candidacy as we like the
policy and I know that's hilarious it's
like what policy we like the policy but
Trump is divisive Trump is damaging to
the Republican party's chances of
winning we don't think he can win and
this is part of what former Republican
Congressman Joe Walsh told us yesterday
they like trumpism
but they just don't know that Trump
could win they're just not sure about it
so that's number one and the early signs
from the polling wherein Ron DeSantis is
already beating Trump in many polls even
though he hasn't announced is a sign
that indeed there may be significant
dissent from within the Republican Party
number two
I know that we always say this and it
never happens Trump does anything he
wants and then still you know becomes
president whatever Trump's past conduct
including the sort of culmination of
multiple impeachments inciting the
Insurrection at the U.S Capitol
Etc
May acutely weaken him and make him
vulnerable to attacks from others from
within and outside of his party
in a way that was not the case during
prior elections because in 2016 was
before the Insurrection and 2020 was
before the Insurrection we don't know to
what degree that is going to impact uh
the campaign and how it will affect
Donald Trump
three
um Trump's statements and policies and
inflammatory rhetoric immigration
Mexicans the anti-semitic stuff now it's
conceivable that it will alienate not
the Maga base but the types of folks
that are more in the middle the
independence the I'm a republican but I
don't love Trump but I'd probably vote
for him except maybe now it's just
gotten Beyond The Pale we know that
there's anti-Semitism and xenophobia and
racism in the Republican party but it's
not complete in total and that may
impact Trump if Trump decides to go
fully steam full steam ahead on that in
his uh 2024 run and he seems like maybe
he is the rhetoric that he has been
focusing on at rallies when he was still
having them was anti-trans uh
anti-immigrant uh ridiculing people from
all sorts of different walks of life so
that is something that could have an
impact legal challenges this is another
layer to this Trump May well get
indicted there are ongoing
investigations into Financial dealings
there's the possibility of criminal
charges there are civil suits all of
this stuff could number one be a
distraction from the campaign
but maybe more importantly
it really could undermine his
credibility as a candidate how is a
republican electorate that already seems
to have cooled on Trump going to react
if the guy is under indictment and being
prosecuted are they going to say well we
should go to somebody less controversial
with fewer encumbrances or is it going
to activate them and get them to say
they're going to indict my president
I'll show them by supporting Trump it's
unpredictable it's an open question I
don't think we'll know if and until it
happens and then there's the financial
aspect to this uh Trump has grifted
donors for a very long time
um but he may struggle to fundraise he
may have real problems fundraising uh
from certain donors particularly donors
who would be hesitant to contribute to
Trump because of the potential legal
problems uh people unwilling to con
contribute to Trump because they'd
prefer someone else like a DeSantis and
just want to wait to see does de Santa
say he's going to run and that could
weaken Trump early so it is very
difficult to predict what will happen
it's also all starting so early
potentially even ill-advised that it's
starting so early in the sense that you
know Trump seemed to think it was better
for him legally to announce early even
though Merritt Garland of others have
said it's really not going to make a
difference we're going to do what we
have to do but these are the potential
reasons that Trump May struggle the
obstacles he may face and a lot of it is
going to come down to does Ron DeSantis
actually run for this thing the latest
polling is unbelievable for Ron DeSantis
good habits have to be sustainable in
order to become habits it has to be
something you'll actually do and when it
comes to nutrition some people have
hours to plan out every meal their exact
vitamin intake I'm not doing any of that
I don't have the time here's what's
sustainable for me I start my day with
just a single scoop of ag-1 from
athletic greens it gives me the entire
day's worth of the 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics I want
from whole food sources it's just simple
it's just one scoop of ag1 I get all the
nutrients I want I don't have to do any
math use my protractor my TI-83 or take
a bunch of different capsules and pills
it's not some kind of wacky supplement
making a bunch of crazy claims you know
I would not promote something like that
ag1 is just a simple product it does
what it says it does it gives you the
daily nutrients and vitamins you likely
want vitamin A C E magnesium zinc
potassium in one simple scoop you keep
your body nourished you'll also get a
free year supply of vitamin D which I
take in the winter plus five free travel
packs at athleticgreens.com Pacman the
link is down below